Gareth would love to hear how you
construct an action scene or sequence
are you storyboarding it are you
planning it out blow-by-blow is it
spontaneous in some sense I'm I'm like a
terrible artist I can't draw at all so I
tend to avoid storyboards you know he's
laughing already
but what we do is because it's really a
hard actually to capture like the
martial arts movement with like a still
image so what we tend to always do is we
make like a video storyboard so we'll
work on the car if you designed together
first and then once we've settled on
what the actual scene is going to be and
the structure of it then after that then
we all kind of like go through the kahan
DCAM just in the office with a couple of
crash mats and videotape this whole
process and we start to figure out what
shot were angle what edit is gonna be
best serving to that piece of
choreography so we never really do
anything where it's like I soaked a wide
shot master and then get coverage this
this and this and try to figure out in
the Edit it's all kind of predetermined
and that's all in that pre-production
stage of it so we end up having at the
end of it like this sort of guide video
that we can use and the tells all the
different departments you know okay in
this shot it's this piece of
choreography and this shot you need to
have this makeup prepared ready for this
guy and it's a good good way to
communicate everything and everyone
understands I'm the full fluidity of the
shot and the Edit as well now I
understand that it looks you know like a
continuous fight but really you're
stopping you're applying makeup
Iko what are you doing in between takes
because you've got to keep that momentum
up they're punching you they're applying
new wounds what are you doing to keep
yourself going as an actor listening to
Toni Braxton in Aragon fighting
passenger and adrenaline it then yeah
can ascend to the top
call me seven come in second position
this fight interest
Kurama be hit us at Lompoc Robbie
besides had to do a young 10 smoky lama
but then I can then you think that was
like a joke which song break my heart
okay actually I have something for you
here on Baron kana own took man what
Libby baaaack film Hollywood no under
burn Connor took memoir by boneyard film
Hollywood yeah come on Keenan lastly so
the cameras I understand that you
purchased two red cameras which you know
you knew you had one hundred and thirty
day shoot or whatever and that you
thought it would be financially best off
how are you passing them between cars
you're going what sixty miles an hour
basically we were all kind of a little
bit nervous and on that shot
specifically more nervous than anything
else because usually when we do like a
pass off like we did on the first raid
it was with a fig rig setup so that at
least from one DOP to the other there's
like a it's a space to grab so if you
gotta figure a cure
you're passed into another DOP he can
grab here and here and it's like a clear
defined area where he can comfortably
take the camera and control it for the
car chase one what we did was we we
couldn't because of the window space was
too small we couldn't put on a fig rig
and also because
the comfort zone of like being able to
kind of maneuver the camera the way they
wanted to they didn't want to be locked
in with certain sort of like sidearm
grips so they literally held it like a
box handheld entirely so there was just
holding the cube with the camera and
then pulling it out through the window
and then panning it and then waiting for
the connector out to come up pushing it
through the open space and then the next
DP would come in and just grab whatever
part was available to grab so it was
really nerve-wracking while we were
shooting it because you know we're on
we're hanging by the road nearby so yeah
we had to be very very careful not to
drop anything but thankfully they
executed it well okay thank you thank
you thank you